[Musique]
la vidéo de cette infirmière chantant au
chevet d'une personne en fin de vie a
fait le tour de la toile
josé gariépy chante pour tous ces
patients dès que le moment s'y prête
ward point fort
parce que ça les apaise pour toutes
sortes de raisons ça cherche à les
reconnecter avec la réalité dans les cas
où les personnes sont confuses où ça
donne juste un petit moment où la
personne est bien ça fait une pause le
ciel de ce nous peut s'effondrer en ces
temps de pandémie
elle chantait davantage je suis ce genre
d'infirmières que de la misère à prendre
c'est beau c'est vraiment une belle
profession mais je trouve que le côté
humain c'est ce qui fait toute la
différence
je suis souvent celles qui vont voir la
famille qui apporte la chaise pour
quelqu'un ça souvent qui est important
c'est la boîte de kleenex
pour josée carrier pis le chant est une
seconde nature dès l'enfance et chante
dans des chorales
elle poursuit pendant ses études
supérieures et fait aujourd'hui partie
du choeur bénévoles de l'om et du choeur
classique de montréal ont peu de plats
une façon apporter du réconfort apporté
du soutien
moi ma façon c'est le chant quand je
chante et que je les étincelles dans les
yeux du passé ça n'a pas de prix
[Musique]
ici à smoke rails at radio canada
montréal
[Musique]
nice